in cooling mondays strike protesters in
Hong Kong directly targeted the
territory's economy to make their
political points but the protests which
started in June have already been having
a financial impact shoppers are staying
away
retail revenues in June were down to
seven percent year-on-year figures for
July and August are expected to show
much bigger drops still business is
terrible terrible people have lost the
desire to spend tourists to are missing
especially those from mainland China
mainlanders like us are afraid to run
into protests I won't be rushing back
I rather wait until it or craziness down
tourists losing confidence in Hong Kong
is one thing but if international credit
rating agencies do too that could be
disastrous poll tes con King go and
escalate and become uncontrollable then
that will have significant impact on
Hong Kong's okay ready waiting Hong
Kong's current credit rating scores are
similar to those of the United States
they're a lot better than mainland
China's because Hong Kong is seen as
economically and legally independent the
protests could mean a downgrade either
because they make Hong Kong a more
difficult place to do business or
because evidence of Beijing asserting
its authority would undermine the
independence that many consider makes
Hong Kong special a town grade would
mean Hong Kong's government and any firm
listed here pays more to borrow Hong
Kong's economy was already sluggish
weighed down by the us-china trade war
and sky-high house prices were beginning
to dip properties and removable sa and
you can't escape from the impact of the
political instability so not many people
are going to enter the market in this
kind of situation the protests could tip
Hong Kong into recession it's too soon
to know the full impact of the protests
economic data takes a month or more to
feed through and who knows whether the
chaotic scenes here have reached their
climax or are going to get worse but
what has been lost already is Hong
Kong's reputation for stability that
will have a cost even if it's unclear
yet how great that cost will be Andrew
Thomas al-jazeera
Hong Kong